في سنه 2010 كان العالم بيحاول يصحصح من
الكارثه اللي نفضته قلبته على دماغه من
سنتين بس وهي الازمه الماليه العالميه في
2008 والبنوك كانت بتقع زي قطع الدومينو
سنتين بس كانوا كفيلين بانهم يمسحوا اكتر
من 300 بنك امريكي من على وش الارض
ويفقروا عشرات الملايين من الامريكيين ده
غير تاثير الازمه الرهيب في جميع انحاء
العالم في الوقت ده الرئيس الامريكي
الاسبق براك اوباما كان لسه ماسك جديد من
سنتين
هو تقريبا نفس عمر الازمه العالميه
والمظاهرات والاحتجاجات الاقتصاديه
والعماليه في كل الولايات الامريكيه
تقريبا يعمل ايه بقى اوباما وادارته في
السيرك اللي لقوا نفسهم فيه ده هقول لك
شايفين حضراتكم الصوره اللي قدامكم دي دي
صوره اتاخدت يوم الاربع 21 يوليو سنه 2010
وهي لاوباما وهو بيوقع على مشروع قانون
غايه في الاهميه والخطوره اسمه وحواليه
مجموعه مسؤولين يمكن تعرفوا بعضهم
رئيسه مجلس النواب وقتها نانسيبلوسى وزعيم
الاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ وقتها هريرت ورغم
الناس التقيله اللي في الصوره الا ان
الاتنين دول تحديدا هم اللي كانوا عرسان
الفرح بسبب هندستهم لمشروع القانون ده
اللي تسمى على اسمائهم رئيس اللجنه
المصرفيه بمجلس شيوخ وقتها رئيس لجنه
الخدمات الماليه في مجلس النواب وعايز
حضراتكم تحفظه شكل بارن بالذات علشان
هنرجع له بعد شويه فرض قانون دوت فرانك
اصلاحات شامله خلقت رقابه صارمه على
النظام المالي الامريكي بهدف حمايه
الاقتصاد والمستهلكين ومنع تكرار الازمه
الماليه العالميه مره ثانيه طب ازاي حط
لوائح ماليه جديده على النظام المصرفي زي
حظر انواع معينه من التداول المحفوف
بالمخاطر وحدد متطلبات صارمه جدا لضمان ان
البنوك هتقدر تستوعب الخسائر غير المتوقعه
وهتقدر تتحمل السحب المفاجئ بكميات ضخمه
الاموال المدعيه وخلى فيه فحوصات ورق
حاولوا يلعبوها بطريقه تانيه ويخففوا من
حدته وقواعده الصارمه ففضلوا يحاربوا
ويصرفوا ملايين الدولارات على مدار 8 سنين
لحد ما نجحوا اخيرا في سنه 2018 ونتيجه
نجاحهم ده كانت الكارثه الماليه الجديده
اللي ظهرت بعدها بخمس سنين وتحديدا خلال
النص الاول من شهر مارس الحالي لما سقطت
اولى قطع دومينو هو بنك فايه هو اللي حصل
في 2018 وايه علاقته بانهيار البنوك
الامريكيه ومين المسؤول عن ده وايه اللي
حصل قبل كده ووصلنا للوضع ده وايه حكايه
بارن فرانك ده دي اسئله مهمه جدا هنحاول
نجاوب عليها مع بعض في حلقه النهارده بس
قبل ما نبدا بفكركم باشتراك في القناه
بفكركم برضو ان كل حلقاتنا اللي فاتت
مترجمه للغه الانجليزيه فما تنسوش
تشاركوها مع اصحابكم الاجانب وتعرفوهم
علينا انا اشرف ابراهيم المقبل الاقتصادي
عايز اشكر شركه على رعايتها الحلقه دي هي
شركه تداول مرخصه من اقوى الهيئات
العالميه زي هيئه الخ دمات الماليه في
سيشل من خلالها تقدر تتداول الاسهم
والمعادن والعملات ولو ما عندكش خبره في
التداول فتقدر تنسخ صفقات المتداولين
الناجحين ما تضيعش فرصه الحصول عالميه في
الميه بونص لو فتحت حسابك في ثواني من
خلال اللينك الموجود في وصف الفيديو وفي
تعليقات فيسبوك
[موسيقى]
بعد اقرار قانون دوت فرانك سنه 2010 جميع
البنوك الامريكيه اللي عندها اصول باكثر
من خمسين مليار دولار لحد عملاقه
تحت السيطره وبقى لكل شغال على ميه بيضاء
زي ما بيقولوا ما فيش انحرافات ماليه ما
فيش منتجات ماليه خطره في اختبارات دوريه
بتتعمل لجميع البنوك لضمان قدرتها على
مواجهه مشاكل سيوله وغيرها طب مين اللي
كان بيفرق علشان يفلت من بعض اجراءات
القانون ده البنوك الصغيره ومتوسطه الحجم
جحافل من المديرين التنفيذيين للبنوك دي
واللي بتسمى بالمقرضين الاقليميين او
البنوك الاقليميه كانوا بيضغطوا بكل الطرق
على كونجرس الامريكي علشان يخففه من حده
قانون دوت فرانك صرفوا ملايين الدولارات
على جماعات الضغط علشان يكسبوا اصوات
تساعدهم على تغيير القانون زي ما قلنا
خمنوا بقى مين ابرز البنوك اللي ضغطوا على
الكونجرس لاضعاف القانون وقتها بالضبط
المديرين التنفيذيين للبنوك اللي انهارت
خلال الايام اللي فاتت ومعاهم المديرين
التنفيذيين لبعض البنوك اللي عندهم دلوقتي
بوادر ازمه ثقه واحتمال تقع هي كمان
الفتره الجايه على راس المديرين
التنفيذيين دول
الرئيس التنفيذ لبنك سيليكون فالي او اس
بي اللي كان بيطير البنك لحد قبل ساعات من
انهياره يوم 10 مارس اللي فات في سنه 2015
واقف جريك بيكر قدام لجنه مجلس شيوخ علشان
يقنعهم بتخفيف اجراءات قانون على البنوك
المتوسطه والصغيره اللي زيه طب كانت ايه
مشكله الراجل ده هو واللي زيه مع القانون
بالضبط بيكرر قل اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ ان
الاجراءات اللي قانون دوت فرانك فرضها
علينا بتزود الاعداء بتاعه البنوك متوسطه
الحجم وده بيقلل بدون سبب وجيه من قدرتنا
على تقديم الخدمات المصرفيه اللي بيحتاجها
العملا وفضل يجادل بان تكاليف الامتثال
والموارد البشريه اللي هو مضطر يوفرها
علشان الاجراءات التنظيميه لدود فرانك فرض
هتقبل اس في بي على تحويل الموارد لها بدل
الاهتمام بتقديم القروض للشركات الصغيره
والمتناميه اللي بتشكل محركات خلق فرص
العمل في الاقتصاد الامريكي الراجل كان
مركز على فكره ان بنك مش زي عمالقه اللي
المفروض المنظمين يركزوا عليهم تحديدا
بقانون دوت فرانك وانما هو مجرد مفرد صغير
وبالتالي يا جماعه لازم تمرروا تشريع
بيسمح لاس بي بي بتجنب الاف الساعات سنويا
اللي البنك بيقضيها في اختبارات الاجهاد
واعداد خطط التسويه وفضل ياكد على قدره
بنك اس في بي على اداره المخاطر القويه
وانهم فاهمين قوي في السوق اللي هم شغالين
فيه باختصار رسالته الحقيقيه للمشارعين
كانت كده طلعوا البنوك الصغيره والمتوسطه
دي من دماغكم شويه لانه ما فيش خطوره منها
وركزوا على الحيتان الكبيره بس خلال
الفتره دي بنك اس في بي انفق نص مليون
دولار على الضغط وزي ما قلنا ما كانش هو
البنك الوحيد اللي كان بيحارب علشان يخفف
من القواعد التنظيميه لقانون دوت فرانك
فاكرين فرانك اللي قلنا في اول الحلقه
متنسوهوش وهنرجع له بارمي هو مهندس رئيس
لقانون اصلاح ويستريد وحمايه المستهلك
واللي القانون اتسمى على اسمه هو وكريستوت
زي ما قلنا في المقدمه يعني يعتبر الاب
الروحي للقانون اللي البنوك المتوسطه
والصغيره مخنوقه منه وبتحاربه المهم سيد
تقاعد سنه 2013 يعني بعد ثلاث سنين من
اقرار القانون اللي هو عمله وبعد ما تقاعد
وبشكل دراماتيكي مفاجئ وغريب تحول لتاييد
التغييرات وبدا يدعم تخفيف البنود
الرئيسيه للقانون تخيلين اللي حصل طب خذوا
الكبيره بقى في 2015 انضم بارن فرنك لمجلس
اداره بنك سجنيتشر بنك وبالتالي تحول بشكل
كامل للفريق اللي عاوز يخفف الاجراءات عن
البنوك المتوسطه والصغيره بعد ما كان واحد
من
انه لو تم تخفيف اللوائح على البنوك
الاقليميه هيتوفر رسمه لاضافه للبنوك دي
هيوصل ل 4 مليار دولار سنويا وهيكونوا
متاحين للاقراض وعلشان يايد رايه قال
شوفوا السيد اللي عمل القانون نفسه هو
اللي بيدعو للتخفيف منه المهم نرجع لا
قبلها بشويه وتحديدا شهر نوفمبر 2016 لما
دونالد ترامب فاجئ العالم ونجح في
الانتخابات الامريكيه ودخل البيت الابيض
وطبعا مش محتاجه اقول لكم ان ترامب كان من
اكبر المناصرين لتخفيف القيود اللي فرضها
قانون دفع عنك وده كان جزء من وعوده في
حملته الانتخابيه اصلا وعلشان كده بعد
اسبوع واحد من تواليه لمنصبه اسبوع واحد
بس وصف قانون دوت فرانك بانه كارثه ووعد
بتغييره وقد كان في شهر مايو سنه 2018
يعني بعد عشر سنين من الازمه الماليه
العالميه وافق الكونجرس على تحرير
العفاريت من الام ام وحرر الاف البنوك
الصغيره والم من القواعد الصارمه اللي
فرضها قانون دوت فرانك سنه 2010 وقع ترامب
القانون الجديد قانون تحرير البنوك وقال
وقتها نصا انه حقا يوم عظيم لامريكا
تعالوا بقى نشوف القانون اللطيف الجديد ده
عمل ايه بالظبط وكان نتيجته ايه قانون دوت
فرانك كان بيقول ان اي بنك عنده اصول اقل
من 50 مليار دولار مش هيطبق عليهم القواعد
الصارمه اللي بتحكم القطاع المصرفي جه
قانون ترامب ورفع الحد ده وخلاه 250 مليار
دولار يعني اي بنك اصوله 250 مليار دولار
او اقل فهو حيفلت من القواعد التنظيميه
المشدده وده بالظبط اللي كانت عايزاه
البنوك الصغيره والمتوسطه لانه بعد ما رفع
الحد الادنى للاصول اللي بيمتلكها البنوك
فهو خرج الاف البنوك من قبضه تخيلوا
حضراتكم بعد التعديل ده في كان بنك بقى
بينطبق عليه القواعد التنظيميه الصارمه
بتاع الدود فرانك اقل من 10 امريكيه كبيره
بس والباقي هيلعب براحته بدون رقابه مشدده
خدوا بالكم علشان النقطه دي مهمه جدا
وخطيره معنى الكلام اللي فات ده ان الاف
البنوك الامريكيه المتوسطه والصغيره زي
اسمي
وغيرهم ما بقاش مطلوب منهم الاتي لا بقى
مطلوب منهم يحافظوا على مستويات معينه من
السيوله وبالتالي يكون عندهم قدره على
امتصاص الخسائر ولا بقى مطلوب منهم
الامتثال لاختبار الاجهاد سواء اللي
بيعملوا البنك بنفسه لاختبار نتانتو
المصرفيه او اللي بيتعمل عليه من
الفيدرالي الامريكي ولا بقى مطلوب منه
تقديم خطط دوريه وحديثه لاغلاق البنك في
حاله حدوث ازمه كل دي كانت اجراءات كانت
لازم البنوك تعملها وبالتالي كانت بتساعد
على كشف عيوب اي بنك ومشاكله بدري تنفيزا
لقانون دوت فرانك في شهر مايو 2018 الكلام
ده كله انتهى على اي ترامب بالنسبه مثلا
لمتطلبات راس المال والسيوله الاجراء ده
كان بيفرض على البنوك منها البنوك
المتوسطه اللي زي از في بي انها تحتفظ
بكميه نقود كافيه تكون قريبه من ايدها
بحيث تقدر تصمت في اوقات العاصفه ايه اللي
حصل بقى في الواقع بالنسبه لبنك اسفي بي
مثلا اول قطع الدومينو اللي انهارت بدايه
من 2020 بدا البنك يتلقى ودائع بكميات
ضخمه وبوتيره سريعه وحجم الودايا نط من 49
مليار دولار سنه 2018 ل 102 مليار دولار
في 2020 السنه اللي بعدها على طول حصلت
قفز اكبر في حجم الوديه ووصلت في 2021 ل
189.2 مليار دولار في الحاله دي البنك معه
ودايع ضخمه ومش عارف يقرضها المفروض يعمل
ايه اداره بنك اس في بي عملت اسوا حاجه
ممكن تتعمل ضخه معظم السيوله في اصول ذات
عوائد مرتفعه وهي هنا كانت سندات طويله
الاجل ذات العائد الثابت البنك في اللحظه
دي كان اشبه بفار بيجري ورا قطعه جبنه ومش
حاجه تانيه غيرها قطعه الجبنه هنا كانت
ارتفاع الارباح لمستوى قياسي وصل 52% سنه
2021 وبالتالي ده ساعد في ارتفاع تقييم
البنك بما يزيد عن 40 مليار دولار ولكن
حقيقه الامر انهم كانوا بيدخلوا في
المصيده هنا البنك عمل كارثه اول حاجه
محتفظش بقدر معين من السيوله علشان يقدر
يمتص اي عمليات سحب مفاجاه وده طبعا لانهم
فلتوا من القانون اللي كان بيفرض عليهم ده
ونتيجه لده في نهايه السنه اللي فاتت
البنك كان فيه 15 مليار دولار بس كاش حد
هيقول لي عادي يا اشرف ما هو ممكن البنك
يبيع السندات لو احتاج لكاش ولا ايه هنا
بقى هتيجي الغلطه التانيه اللي ارتكبها
البنك انه ركز معظم الودايا اللي كانت
بتيجي له في سندات طويله الاجل بعائد ثابت
وبالتالي ما كانش في تحوط من ارتفاع اسعار
الفائده وفقا لوثائق اطلعت عليها لجنه
الاصول والخصوم في البنك في اواخر سنه
استلم التوصيه داخليه بضروره شراء سندات
قصيره الاجل علشان يقللوا مخاطر التعرض
لخساير كبيره لو اسعار الفائده ارتفعت
بسرعه ده طبعا كلام جميل ايه اللي حصل في
التوصيه دي بقى اترمت في الزباله
والمسئولين التنفيذيين في البنك فضلوا
يضخوا سيوله في السندات طويله الاجل علشان
يعظموا الارباح طبعا خيار السندات دي كان
خيار مدمر لما البنك احتاج للسيوله بسرعه
الامر المثير للسخريه ان البنك قعد 8 شهور
ما فيهوش حد بيشغل منصب مهم جدا وخطير وهو
كبير مسؤول المخاطر او تشييف ريسك افسر
المعروف اختصارا بسي ار او من شهر ابريل
2022 ولحد شهر يناير 2023 البنك ما عينش
حد مكان لورا ايزوريتا اللي استقالت من
منصبها كسي ار او ودي فتره كانت خطيره جدا
والبنك بيواجه فيها تحديات ومخاطر كثيره
كبير مسؤوله المخاطر ده يا جماعه هو اللي
يتوقع وبيدير جميع انواع المخاطر اللي
بتواجه الشركه او البنك في حالتنا هنا
سواء كانت المخاطر دي تنظيميه او تشغيليه
او تنافسيه وبيرفع تقاريره لمجلس الاداره
والرئيس التنفيذي مباشره وعلى فكره قبل
قانون تحرير البنوك في 2018 كان مسئول
المخاطر كان لازم يكون موجود ما كانش فيه
اي بنك يقدر يقعد شهر واحد مش ثمان شهور
من غير سي ار او لكن طبعا بعد قانون ترامب
البنك ما بقاش ملزم بتعيين حد طب ازاي اسم
بيه ادار المخاطر بتاعته في الثمان شهور
دول الله اعلم المهم بعد ما الفيدرالي
الامريكي الله يهد حيله بدا يرفع اسعار
الفائده من شهر مارس 2022 من صفر تقريبا
لما يقرب من 5% دلوقتي بنك اس في بي لبس
في الحيطه وخسر اكثر من 16 مليار دولار
خساير غير محققه على حيازاته من السندات
طويله الاجل اللي كان مركز عليها وهنا
تظهر اهميه اختبارات الاجهاد اللي اتشالت
من على البنك بعد قانون تحرير البنوك بتاع
ترامب وجامعه اختبار الاجهاد او الاستنج
بشكل مختصر جدا هو اسلوب محاكاه حاسوبي
بنتوقع من خلاله ازاي البنك هيتصرف في
المواقف السيئه المختلفه زي ارتفاع اسعار
الفائده مثلا ولا هي هنا تسببت في انهيار
بنك هنا كلمه السر في العك اللي حصل ده في
مصطلح اسمه مخاطر اسعار الفائده في دفتر
البنوك او
ذا بنك والمعروف اختصارا باي ار ار بي بي
واللي من خلاله بنعرف المخاطر الحاليه او
المتوقعه على راس مال البنك وارباحه بسبب
تقلبات اسعار الفائده وفي حاجه اسمها
اداره مخاطر اسعار الفائده او مانيج واللي
هي من خلالها بقدر اقلل من مخاطر اسعار
الفائده عن طريق شراء سندات ذات فترات
مختلفه او عن طريق التحوط لاستثمارات
الداخله الثابت من خلال مقيدات اسعار
الفائده او الخيارات او مشتقات اسعار
الفائده التانيه كل دي اختبارات وادوات
لازم البنوك تعملها بشكل منتظم لكن ده كله
ما حصلش في بنك اس بي لان ترامب عطل كل ده
بالنسبه للبنوك اللي وصولها بتقل عن 250
مليار دولار زي ما وضحنا طبعا لو البنك
كان خاضع لقواعد اكثر صرامه ولو المنظمين
عملوا لي اختبار اجهاد كانت نقاط ضعف
ومشاكله هتبان بسهوله وما كانش هيتم
السماح له بشراء سندات خزانه طويله الاجل
وما كانتش محفظته من الاستثمارات دي
هتتضخم ل57% من اجمالي اصولها ودي نسبه
خطيره جدا ما فيش بنك امريكي تاني وصلها
اعلى نسبه كانت 42% من بين 74 بنك امريكي
تاني منافس وبالتالي ما كناش هنشوف بي
اللي اصبح البنك رقم 16 من بين اكبر
البنوك الامريكيه بينهار علشان يبقى تاني
اكبر انهيار مصرفي في التاريخ الامريكي
واول انهيار بعد الازمه الماليه العالميه
في 2008 وما كناش هنشوف انهيار بنك بعده ب
48 ساعه علشان يبقى تالت اكبر انهيار
مصرفي في تاريخ الولايات المتحده وما كناش
هنشوف انهيار سيلفر بنك ودول بالمناسبه مش
هيكونوا نهايه الازمه فاكرين هل السيمونز
رئيس التنفيذ البنك ساينس اللي كان بيحارب
هو كمان علشان يتم تخفيف قانون وقت تصوير
الحلقه وكانت موديل كانت بتستعد لتخفيض
التصنيف الائتماني للبنك ده هو وخمس بنوك
اقليميه تانيه البنوك الخمسه هم بنك ماركه
وبنكرب وبنك انتراست وبنك يو ام بي في
البنك الخامس هو بنك فرست هل البنوك دي
هتصمد بعد التخفيض الرسمي لتصنيفاتهم
الائتمانيه قبل ما اصور الحلقه على طول
كان في جزء من اجابه السؤال ده وتحديدا
بتكلم على البنك الخامس اللي هو بنك فيرست
بابل البنك ده قبل تصوير الحلقه مباشره
حصلت له عمليه انق كبيره جدا ولكن الانقاذ
المره دي كان جاي من عمالقه طول ستريت في
محاوله لوقف الازمه المتصاعده من خلال دعم
البنوك المتعثره بنك اوف امريكا جولد مان
سيكس
وافقوا على ايداع 30 مليار دولار في البنك
المتعثر اللي اصبح بيعاني فجاه من عمليات
سحب عملائه لودائهم بعد انهيار اس بي
الانهيار المالي اللي حصل لبعض البنوك
الامريكيه ارسل موجات من الصدمه في جميع
انحاء العالم رغم تدخل الحكومه الامريكيه
ممثله في الفيدرالي الامريكي وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه في اجراء استثنائي
واعلانهم ضمان جميع ودائع العملاء في
البنوك اللي انهارت دي ولكن تظل مشكله
البنوك دي بلا حل لحد وقت تصوير الحلقه
لحد هنا انا خلصت كلامي وكالعاده عند سؤال
لحضراتكم تفتكروا الازمه دي هتعدي والدنيا
هتتلم ولا الموضوع هيوسع لخارج الولايات
المتحده زي ما شفنا في سويسرا وهتبقى ازمه
عالميه جديده اتابع كل اجاباتكم في
التعليقات قوليلي بيفكر يتداول الاسهم
والعملات والمعادن حيلاقي رابط شركه انجل
روكورس في التعليقات ما تنسوش تشتركوا في
القناه زي ما اتفقنا ويا ريت لو عجبتكم
الحلقه تعملوا لايك وشير للفيديو واهم
حاجه تحكوا لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا يمكن
نستفيدوا سلام
[موسيقى]